サッブ パパッス アカラナン クサラッソ ウパ サンプラ サチット パリヨ ダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では あの 今から...はい
はい あの 今からあの...午後
まあ時間 最後の時間まで決まってないんですからね
まあいろいろあのウェーサーカ祭りにちなんで
あの お釈迦様の世界を
あの体験していただこうかなと思います
僕は あの大乗仏教のお坊様方も少々お話をするとは思います
で まず皆様ご存知のように
この なんで日本と違って我々の仏教で
このウェーサーカ 三事件というかね
三大聖なる事件ですね
一緒にお祝いのかと まあそれは歴史的にもう確かではないんですが
おそらく あの 仏教の教えの中から考えたことではないかなと思います
で お釈迦様がこのブッダになるということは
もう生命として究極の位置でありまして
それは生半可な気持ちでできることではありません
あまりも日本語で数字で言うのはすごく難しいんですが
長い間修行をしてきたんですね
で その修行っていうのは
いろいろ能力身についてきたんですね
だからお釈迦様は生まれるときももう完全な人格者なんですね
で パーリ語でパーラミターと言って
日本語でパーミットと言うんですね
数字では この  えーと 40
万...劫かける10の180乗なんですね
そこは数字でね 計算してみてください
すごい少ない数字ですね
それぐらい 劫 劫っていうのは宇宙が一つ現れて消える時間なんですね
その劫は一つで あの あれぐらい40万かける10の180乗ぐらい
劫単位でお釈迦様がこのあらゆる修行をして
あらゆる徳を積んでパーラミタを完成したんですね
だから人格者としてはもう誰にもかなわない能力を持っていたんですね
そのすごい徳を持っていたんだから
お釈迦様は涅槃に入られても
その徳がずっと続くんです
だから これはお釈迦様には意味がないんだけど
我々はそこをいただいているんです
で あの スリランカでは
あの 国丸ごとウェーサーカ祭りをやりますけど
政府も政府も正式的にウェーサーカ祭りを行いますし
国民みんなね ただ 一つ言いたいところは
この何回もいろんなところでウェーサーカ祭りを日本でね
行ってきましたけど どんな時でもものすごくいい天気に恵まれます
だから我々は正しい日にちでウェーサーカ祭りやってないんだけど
時間ずらしてますね こちらの都合で
名古屋 大阪 いろんな日にちで
私も飛び回らなくちゃいけなかったしね
いつでもどこに行っても
その日に限ってものすごくいい天気なんです
それはお釈迦様の徳のおかげやと思います
で すごい珍しく あの 自分の国でもものすごい猛暑でもう我慢できないぐらいみんな慣れてないんだからね
あまり暑さにはね かなり子供たちは病気になっている問題ありますけど
それでもこの間ではそれはないんですね
雨が降ってます 結構 そういうことで
お釈迦様の徳っていうのは
我々にもそこをその恩恵をいただけることはできるんですね
だからそのできる方法っていうのは
何かしたらお釈迦様と何とか付き合ってみることなんですね
だから私たちは お釈迦様は涅槃に入られているんだけど
お花をあげたり 食事をしてあげたり
お世話してあげたり いろいろお釈迦様と親しみを作るんです
で 私たちっていうのは
毎日欠かさず あの お釈迦様との付き合いをね
するんですね お釈迦様は神より偉いんですけど
神みたいな恐れる存在ではないんですね
私たちは自分たちの父親として思わなくちゃいけないんですね
本物の父親 すべての生命の
ですから この父親に会うような気持ちで
父親と仲良くするような気持ちで
お釈迦様と付き合ってみた方がよろしいんです
そういうことで 今日は軽くお釈迦様に会いに来たんだからね
何言われるかわからないぐらいから
で 御降臨になっておると
それでお釈迦様 あれほど気が狂うほど長い時間修行を積んだのは
ブッダになるためなんですね
そこで面白いことがありまして
お釈迦様がこの修行が始まる前にも悟る能力を持っていたんです
この悟る能力を持っていたんだけど
たくさん人々にも道を教えてあげたいんだと
自分一人だけ苦しみを輪廻
苦しみを脱出してね ちょっとどうかなと
そういうわけでお釈迦様がこの我々のことを心配して
我々のことを憐れんで
あれほど前言った数字もう一度思い出してください
40万かける あの十の八十八十乗ですね
まあそれぐらい広単位で
あの修行して修行してきたんですね
皆さんは知っているジャータカ物語では一部のね
お釈迦様の過去のことを書かれていますね
全てではないんですけどね
そこで人間として生まれたら
それで終了ですね 輪廻転生は
で ゴールに達しましたと
中国の最後のところに決まったと
これからもう何もやることはないんだと
終わりましたという意味で
お釈迦様は生まれるんですね
それで終わりましたと言っても
ブッダになった瞬間で本格的に悟って終わったんですね
それからまたやることはないんですね
まだお釈迦様は体を持ってありましたからね
それで 45年経ったところで体もストップしたんです
それで終わりの終わり
そういうことで すべてゴールに達しました
ゴールに達しました ゴールに達しましたという意味で
この 3つの出来事を昔の阿羅漢たちが一気に決めたんじゃないかなと思います
で あとここは喋りますが
ものすごい面白いね お釈迦様の人生っていうのはね
あれほど能力あったのに
いつでもユーモアで説法するんです
私はいろいろ冗談を言うと
みんなに笑われちゃってもう仕方がないんだけど
お釈迦様の説法の中でもかなりユーモアがいっぱい入っているんです
時々厳しいユーモアもありますけど
ものすごい厳しいことを言ったりするんですけど
このまあ政治ぶったりはしなかったんですね
誰とも仲良くして ちょっと質問されたら
ちょっとユーモアを入れてそれに答えて
でお釈迦様の一つの答えで解決なんですね
だから今日は一つ今思い出したエピソードなんですけど
まあもう一応疲れてるんだけど
前からずーっと 言っていたことばっかり記憶にありますけど
ある日 お釈迦様が祇園精舎に行って
暗黒になる前に比丘たちに出かけますと
報告したんですね 言ったら
まあ比丘たちもお釈迦様と一緒に出かけてしまいますけど
でも最上のね 方々はお釈迦様が出て行っちゃったら
またいつ帰ってくるのかわかりませんしね
寂しいと 止まってほしいと言うんですね
お釈迦様は いえ あの出ること決めたんだからね
如来は決めたことは変えませんよと
みんなに言うんです 如来が決断したら
それは最終的に決断だけど変わりませんよと
すごく言うんです そうすると
王様がね マガダ国王でしたけど
王様が来て お釈迦様お願いしますから
今年こちらで雨具に入らせてくださいと
で 断るんです あのね 決めたことは変えられませんよ
如来は だから残念ですと
それでこの祇園精舎作ってあげたのは
アナンタという在家の方なんですけど
その方は王様よりもお釈迦様のお世話するんですね
毎日比丘たちのね 自分で毎日お布施を用意して
托鉢の和尚さんたちに 200人であろうか
300人であろうか 食事を作ってあげているんです
1日も欠かした欠けたことないんですよ
彼が仏教徒になった日から
それで彼はこれはやばいと思って
お釈迦様に会ってお釈迦様どうぞ
我々は寂しいんだと お釈迦様は今年もこの祇園精舎で雨具に入ってください
お願いします そうしたら断ったんです
いえ 出かけることに決めたんだよと
だからあなたが言うこと聞きませんよと
如来はと すごい厳しい態度でしょうに
それでこのアナンタさんがものすごく落ち込んで
で それと面白いのは だからブッダはだからお釈迦様の仏像があっただけで
写真があっただけで 仏があっただけでも心穏やかになりますよ
本物がいたらどういうことですかね
で この仏画にあるようなすごい堂々たる姿ではなかったんです
すごい痩せていたんです
お釈迦様 本物のお釈迦様は
で なんかデータ見るとね
お釈迦様はそんなにすごい体格ではなかったし
でも仏典ではかくかくかくかく褒め称えて褒め称えて
なんかもう世の中でびっくりするような肉体形でしたよとかね
それだったらね 他の宗教の文献にも出てくる可能性ありますからね
ないんですからね まあごく普通の痩せた方でしたけどね
しかし あの聖なる力は並みじゃないんですね
だからお釈迦様が出て行くのは嫌なんですね
そこでアナンタ王子がアナンタさんがもう落ち込んじゃって
寝込んじゃったんです
それで召使いの女の子がいたんですね
召使いでいたって もう奴隷みたいな格なんですね
一生死ぬまでもう仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですね
で ちっちゃな女の子で
その家で召使いの家族で生まれて
赤ちゃんの時からも遊び回ってそこで大きくなった子なんですね
その子は別にまだまだ仕事もしないし
遊び回っているちっちゃな子供でしょうね
言ったら この自分の主人のところに行って
ご主人様はなんで今日珍しく落ち込んでいるんですか？と
普通すごい元気 活発で動いているのにね
何か調子が悪いのかと聞いたんです
ったら あなたさんが うーん
そうね まあお釈迦様はもう帰っちゃうよ
だからこれは私にとってはね
たまらないんだと だから止まりなさいと言っちゃえばいいんじゃない？ということを言ったら
それは王様さえも頼まったよと
visakha 夫人も頼まったよと断られたんだと
だからその女の子が では私がお釈迦様が止めてもらったらあんたどうしますか？と
私に何をくれるのかい？と
聞いたら あのね 君にお釈迦様止めてもらうことできればね
君を一生自由にして娘にしますよと
で 過去も違いますよ 君を解放して
奴隷制度からね 自由にして娘にしますよと
はい わかりましたと あの女が走ったんですね
祇園精舎に その時はお釈迦様と比丘たちが出かけているんです
お寺から出ているんです
そのちっちゃな女の子がサッサッと行って
お釈迦様のところで土下座して拝んで
お釈迦様は出かけるんでしたと
はい そうだよ 今年もこのお寺で泊まっていただけませんかね？と聞いたら
あのね 君 私に何がくれるんですかと
泊まったら だからお釈迦様っていうのは普通そういうことを絶対言わない性格なんです
だから あのちっちゃな子供に向かって私に何がくれるの？という
言ったら あの子もなかなか負けず嫌いでね
そんなこと言われても
私は貧しいだからね 何も持ってないよ
ご飯一膳もあげることできませんよと
しかし もしお釈迦様が泊まっていただくならば
五戒を守りますと これからしっかりと
それじゃあ約束できますよ
ああ そう では 泊まります
だから このどれほどの人格者かっていうことはね
だから王様の権力よりも
人が五戒守ること 道徳を守ることは優れているんだよという
このすごいメッセージを
こんな小さな出来事で我々に教えてくれるんですよ
だから皆様方は元気で破ってください
理解の王様の指令よりも
国の指令よりも それは破ってでも五戒守った方が価値があるんだろうと
あの小さなエピソードでお釈迦様を教えてくれたんです
だから決めたんだから
もう帰れませんよと言ったお釈迦様がもう出かけて始めて
まだ行者のお寺の門をくぐって通ってなかったんだけど
そこをまた戻ったんです
比丘たちにも比丘たち
比丘たちは今年もこちらで雨期に入ることにしまったよと
だからお坊さんたちはお釈迦様を尊敬しているんだ
お釈迦様によく気分が変わるもんやとは言わなかったんです
それはとんでもない失礼なことだから
簡単に気が変わるわけじゃないんですよ
お釈迦様も狙いは決めたことは決めた
でもあれを知って この出来事をやらなくちゃいけないんですね
我々のために なんで五戒守ることそんなに大事でしょうかというと
国の法律っていうのはもうすぐすぐ変わるもの
大したことはない 政権もちょっとしたことで倒れるし
独裁者自分でいたってもね
後であっけなく殺されるしね
知ってるでしょうね このリビアとかね
本当に悲しい なんかちょっとやりすぎですけどね
あのガダフィさんね まあすごいやられましたしね
で イラクのフセインさんやらね
堂々力強く威張っていたんだけど
もう誰も名前も忘れて忘れてるような感じでね
だからそんなことを守って
んだからって我々得るもの何もないんです
だから五戒っていうのは
生命 輪廻転生する場合は
我々を守ってくれる もうガードなんですね
だからどこで生まれても
我々はたくさん生命と一緒にいなくちゃいけない
たとえ地獄に落ちたってもね
一人ぼっちになりません
たくさん生命がいるんですね
無数に その互いの関係によって命が成り立つんです
だから生命を慈しんだ方がいいんです
殺生しない方がいいんです
まあどう殺生する人は地獄に落ちるわけないんだけど
たとえ殺生したり もう他の生命に残酷な生き方すると
どこに生まれても楽にはいられません
だから地獄に落ちるんですね
やられるところに はい
そういうことで お釈迦様はいろんな場面で生命に真理をずっと語り続けたんですね
で 今日はお釈迦様の誕生の言葉を紹介して
午前中の話を終了したいと思います
で お釈迦様がこの経典は後で午後説明します
詳しく 生まれてすぐ歩いて言葉を喋ったということは
皆様ご存知ですね その言葉はあまりにも大胆過ぎなんですね
アッゴーハマスローカ
この生命の中でね 私こそ独尊であると
私こそ先輩であると 一番トップであると
一切の生命は立場が自分よりは立場が低いんだということなんですね
だからそこでこの自分の道徳を念じて
お釈迦様は母ちゃんの時もう梵天も決まったからね
生まれた時はね で みんな見たらみんな自分の嘘をするんですね
これどういうことかと
だから この一切の生命の中で一番優れている者であるという宣言をしたんです
それはまあ自慢ではないんで
自慢というのは まあ嘘だからでしょうね
自慢というのはね これはまあ事実を言ってはみたんですね
それ知った方が 生命がブッダのことを真剣に聞いて役に立つようになります
そうでない場合 お釈迦様は苦労しなくちゃいけないですね
その例は アッゴーハマスミローカススジェットハマスミローカススセットハマスミローカスアヤマンティマージャティナッティダニプナンバオアッゴーハマスミローカ
ス
生命の中で私が先輩である
セットハマスミローカス一番優れている存在になりましたと
ジェットハマスミっていうのはまたシニア先輩という意味なんですね
アヤンアンティマージャティ
これは私の最後の生まれ
これから生まれます ナッティダニプナンバオ
これから輪廻転生することはありません
終わりました という言葉なんですね
それから普通の母ちゃん父親になって
まあ普通の 35歳まで普通の人生でしたけどね
でも心は違っていたんですね
いつでも だからそういう人類の歴史を見ると
そういう人格者はないんです
偉い人々の話はいくらでもありますけど
あの能力 あの性格 等しいものは存在すらしない
そこで思い出した別なエピソード
サーリプッタ尊者が 智慧の力で言えば
お釈迦様の 2番目なんです
お釈迦様ほど智慧がないんだけど
生命の中でサーリプッタ尊者の智慧に比較できる生命はいません
神々を含むすべての生命の中で
それでサーリプッタ尊者がブッダのことをよく知っているし
お釈迦様が説法を始め
ちょっと始めたら あ 今日はこういうところまでお話しなさって終わりますって知ってるんです
そこまで智慧があるんです
これは世の中に見せるために
お釈迦様がまたいろいろ
からくりってことは失礼ですけどね
いろいろ方便なさるんですね
方便ですね 時々お釈迦様が午後をね
説法を始めて 途中で私はもう背中が痛くなったんだから横になります
でもすごい みんな理解できるように
脳細胞が咲いてくるように説法するんです
途中で疲れました 横になりました
例えば突然説法をやめちゃうと困るでしょう
サーリプッタ尊者はそばにいる時行うんです
その方便は 他のお坊さんがいる時はやらないんです
で サーリプッタ みんなこの話すごい頭が冴えていて
全然眠気もないし まあね
まあお兄さんもちょっと違うかもしれませんだけど
ものすごく精神的に元気ですから
続けて説法してください
で 横になる 横になってもご自分が休む部屋に行けばいいでしょう
に行かないんです みんなそのいるところで横になっているんです
お釈迦様はそばにいるのに
サーリプッタ尊者が説法しなくちゃいけないんです
並大抵の人間にできることじゃないんです
それでお釈迦様がサーリプッタ尊者がどれほど偉大なる方かと世の中に見せるために
そういう方便をとるんです
だからお釈迦様のこの優しさっていうのは
もう考えられないんですね
それであのサーリプッタ尊者だからこう考えるんですね
世の中でね ブッダほどすごい人はね
現れなかったし 今も現れないし
これからも現れないでしょうと
だから これは知恵で考えたことだからね
間違いはありません だからそこをお釈迦様に報告したんですね
私はこう思いますよと
より偉い人は過去でも現れなかったし
現在もいないし 将来も現れないんですと
でお釈迦さん ああ その通りやと言わなかったんです
他のところで言ってるのに
その時お釈迦様が あのね
サーリプッタ あなた私の心知り尽くしている？いえ
とんでもない そんなことでは
過去のブッダたちのことを知り尽くしている？とんでもない
お釈迦様 そんなできるわけじゃないんだと
じゃああんた 将来にあらわるブッダたちのことを知っている？知らない
だったらなんであんな大胆な発言するんですかねと
知らないのに すごい あの人は微妙な論理的なところ
微妙に崩れてたんですね
ちゃんとデータ取らないで結論に達したんですね
そこをお釈迦様叱るんですよ
あの智慧の第一人者を
だから この微妙なこの人を育てる育ち方っていうのは
これかなわない どこにでも誰にもできません
それでサーリプッタ尊者に教えたんです
私はそう信じていると言ってくださいよと
私の信仰だと だってデータがないんだからね
じゃなきゃあんた言ってることは当てにならない話やと
そういうことで お釈迦様にちょっとでも近づくことができれば
どんな人間でも素晴らしい人間になる
悟りに達する 苦しみをなくす
もう一つ ワンキス長老の話
これはワンキス長老じゃないんです
ワンキスっていう尊者ですけどね
うん？何だったっけな
ほか ワンキスじゃない
名前は ちょっと名前を忘れちゃった
もう年寄り説法するんじゃないね
... まあ一応名前なくエピソード言いますね
あるお坊さんがいたんですね
そのお坊さんがなぜ出家したのかって
お釈迦様を見たらものすごい感動するんですね
そのために出家したんです
そうすると いつでもお釈迦様を見ることができるんだと
だからこの人 どう言ってもさすがに一番前に座っちゃうんです
座っていてじーっと顔を見ているんですよ
感動しながら これ お釈迦様がこの人の心を見てね
じーっと待っていたんです
見たい放題 じゃあ見なさいと
迷惑なんですけど ものすごくそこはもう憐れみの気持ちで待っていて
待っていて 待っていて
もしかすると二 三年か分かりません
それはないんですね で
これお釈迦様の説法をね
一回聞いたら人は悟りますし
他の人々は途中で悟るし
この人は何年も一番先のところに座って
一番前に座ってじーっと顔を見ている
もう十分だろうと思ったところでこう言ったんです
キンテーみなポイティカーイナ見ているなという
名前を忘れて思い出せないんですね
あのね お前はね この腐ってる体見て何になるのかと
自分の体でこの腐ってる体を見てね
何になるんですかと よーダンマンパッソイソウマンパッソで
私の教えるこの真理を皆さん真理を体験したら
そこでブッダが誰かとわかりますよと
だからそのエピソードからでも
ブッダの肉体ではなくて
ブッダの智慧を経験してくれる
そうすると ブッダをなんとなく自分の目の前にいるような存在のように体験することができます
ですから そこも一つ我々の教えているポイントです
そのようにお釈迦様がもう世に現れない偉大なる方で
我々にとって 皆様にもお釈迦様の偉大な功徳によって幸福になりますように
早く心が清らかになって解脱に達することができますように
誓願いたしまして 御聴聞を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
サワディーサワディカー
ではよろしくお願いします
あの あまりあの緊張しないで
どくぐそうな気楽で 自分の家にいるような気分で参加してください
楽しく明るく 元気で あの
ブッダの世界を体験しましょう
で 今日はそんなに厳しいあれではないんですからね
うん まずはあの で 私と木下専修お坊さんと皆様で慈悲の辞儀をね
パーリ語と日本語で唱えます
皆様もテキストあるならばありがたいし
なかったらまあ黙って聞いてください
別に  [笑い]特別に罰金とか何もないんですね
あそこではなかったと思いますけどね
うん よろしいですか ありがとうございます
ナモタッセ・バガヴァト・アラハト・サンマ・サンブッダッセ
カラニーラ・マッタ・クサレーナ
ヤンタム・サンタン・パラム・アビサメッジャ
サング・ホジュ・ジャス・ジュジュ・ジャ
シュラ・ジョー・ジャッサム・ドゥ・アナティマーニ
解脱という目的をよくわきまえた人は
静かな場所へ行ってなすべきことがあります
何事にも優れ しっかりして
まっすぐでしなやかで
人の言葉をよく聞き 柔和で高慢でない人になるように
サント・サコー・ジャス・マローチャ・アンタ・キッジョー・ジャサンラム・カルミ
サンティ・インドリヨー・ジャニ・パコー・ジャ・アンタ・ガンド・クエス・アナ・ヌギンド
足ることを知り 手がかからず
雑務少なく簡素に暮らし
もろもろの感覚器官が落ち着いていて
賢明で裏表がなく 財貨に執着しないように
ナチャ・クンダ・サマチャレ・キンチ・エナ・ヴィンニュ・パレ・ウパワディーヨム
ツキノ・ワ・ケーミ・ノントゥ・サンデー・サンター・バワントゥ・スキティ・カンター
智慧ある識者たちが批判するような
どんな小さな過ちも犯さないように
幸福で平安でありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
エーチ・パーナ・ボタンティ・カサーワ・パーワラーワ・アナワ・シーサー
ヴィーガワ・エーマンターワ・マンジ・マーラ・サカーヌ・カトゥーラー
いかなる生命であろうとも
ことごとく動き回る でも動き回らないものでも
長いものでも 大きなものでも
中くらいのものでも 短いものでも
微細なものでも 巨大なものでも
ディンターワーイエランディンターレジャドゥーレワサンティアリドゥーレ
ブータワサンバヴェーシーワサンメサンターバワントゥスキルカンター
見たことがあるものもないものも
遠くに住むものでも 近くに住むものでも
すでに生まれているものも
卵などこれから生まれようとしているものも
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
ネパローパランニクンレターナティマンニエッタカンタチナンカンチ
ビャローサナパティガサンニャーナンニャマンニャッサドゥッカミンチェイヤ
どんな場合でも人を欺いたり軽んじたりしてはいけません
怒鳴ったり 腹を立てたり
お互いに人の苦しみを望んではいけません
マータヤターニヤンプンタン
アーユサエーカプッタマヌランテ
エワンピサンババウテシュマナサンガワイアパリマナン
あたかも母がたった一人の我が子を命がけで守るように
そのようにすべての生命に対しても
無量の慈しみの心を育ててください
メンタンチェサンバロカスミンマナサンバワイアパリマナン
ウンダアトチャティリアンチャアサンバアダンアヴェランアサパンタン
慈しみの心を 一切世間
すべての生命に対して限りなく育ててください
上に下に横周りに住むいかなる生命に対しても
わだかまりのない 恨みのない
敵意のない心を育ててください
ティンチャンチャランナセンノワシャヤノワヤワタッサリガタミンドー
エータンサティンナディッテイアブラッマメタンリハラエジャマウ
立っている時も 歩いている時も
座っている時も あるいは横になっていても
眠っていない限り この慈悲の念をしっかり保っていてください
これが梵天崇高なものの生き方であると言われています
ディンテンチャアノガガンマシーラワダッサネーナサンパンノ
カーメスヴィネイヤゲダンナイジャートゥガンバセイヤンプナエビキ
このように実践する人は
邪見を乗り越え 常に戒を保ち
正見を得て 諸々の欲望に対する執着をなくし
もう二度と五体に宿る輪廻を繰り返すことはありません
エーテーナサンチャワンジェーナポートゥノーラタナンダヤン
エーテーナサンチャワンジェーナポートゥノジャヤマンガラン
エーテーナサンチャワンジェーナサダーソンティカワントゥノ
この真理の言葉の力によって
我らは三宝 仏法僧に守られますように
我らは幸福でありますように
この真理の言葉の力によって
我らは常に安穏でありますように
ありがとうございます
私は考えたのはね 日本の仏教でもね
あの ちょっとあの 自分の国からこちらに来てね
起き上がる時は この本堂の前にね
本尊の前に 仏陀の仏像の前で起き上げたりしてね
私たちとはちょっとやり方がちょっと違うんだけどね
だけど私は考えたら こんなお釈迦様の前で
観音様の前で それからね
いろいろ仏様ありますからね
阿弥陀様とかね 大日如来とか
そういう人々の前で 自分たちが言ったことを繰り返して言うと
うるさいと思わないといけないとか
お釈迦様の前で座ってお釈迦様の前でお釈迦様がおっしゃったことを繰り返しちゃってもね
相当うるさいと思いますよ
で このお経をあげるということは
そういう これは私はただ単にこの何も笑うことないんだから
無理やりそういうことかくだらないことを考えて
自分勝手に笑っちゃいますけどね
で 笑いの手前にネタに仏像とか使っちゃうのはね
まあそれはどうかなと思いますけどね
で だからお経をあげることで
このあげる人が浄化するんですね
だからわざわざ仏像とか何とかなくてもいいんです
ただ 何かあった方が なんとなく自分の気持ちが落ち着くだけなんです
ですから 皆様 自分自身が心が浄化するんだというね
それを理解してお経をあげてみてください
だからとにかくこの意味を感じ取ってください
例えば マーターヤタハニヤンプッタンというね
あたかも何だらかんだら母のね
あった ありましたね どこ行ったっけ？パーリ語で覚えてますけど
日本語は  あたかも母がたった一人の我が子
うん そういうね 母がね
自分の我が子を守っているようにとかね
生命 いつきしも裏切っちゃいけないんだと思ったら
自分自身がその役をね
精神的に演じなくちゃいけないんですね
なんか自分自身が母になった気分ね
すべての生命が私の子供のように大事にしなくちゃいけないんだな
だから そういう風にこのお経をあげると
この自分で自分を浄化する目的でやるのが正しいやり方なんですね
で 一心仏陀やらね 観音様やらね
そんなもうくだらないと思います
そんなもううるさいんだからね
いた人の前に 例えば私の前で私が書いた本を読み上げると
あなたに本を読み上げますからね
よく聞いてくださいと言っちゃうと
私は相当怒ると思いますよ
だから喜んで聞くのは
私が読んだことがない
私一人で読めない 何か誰かがね
読んでくれるならば それはありがたいんですけど
そういうことで これポイントもよく理解してください
お経をあげるべきなんで
お経をあげる場合は あの自分の心が浄化するような気持ちでね
私たちはまあ私たちといったって誰ですかね
まあ一人一人しかいないわけじゃない
私は その気持ちでお経はあげるんですね
まあそれでも時々いろんなことを頭によぎっちゃってね
まあ浄化するところじゃない場合もありますけどね
まあ忙しいとかね 遅くなったとかね
早くお経開けなくちゃとかね
ダラーンと開けちゃいますからね
もう何も感じてない時もありますが
とにかくそういう風に頑張ってみてください
で あの タイのお経をこういう風にね
日常経典とかね いっぱいさせてますからね
そこにあったイントロダクションのところで読んでみたら
このお経をあげるとはなんぞやと
それは比丘はね 朝とかね
午後とかね お釈迦様に礼をする
それは目上の方々 尊敬に値する方々をとことん尊敬しなくちゃいけない
我々にとってお釈迦様が師匠ですからね
で それはもう礼をして
それからその場でずっとお経をあげるということは
お釈迦様から自分が戒めをいただいているんだという気分であげてくださいと
それも一つのいい考え方だと思いますね
今 自分が読んでいるんだけど
本当はお釈迦様が私にお前はこういうふうにしなさいよと言っているような気持ちでいる
だから このお釈迦様から教えをいただいている気持ちでもお経をあげるということになっているんです
余計な話はそれだけね
えーと 次に 続けて まあ時間かかりますが
慈悲の瞑想をやってみます
皆様の手元にもこのテキストあると思います
スクリーンにも映します
これは去年作った まあ私は去年のウェーサーカマセだけにしようかなと思って作ったものなんですけど
慌てて急いでね で これは長く生き延びるとは思っていなかったんですけど
で 慈悲の気持ちをいろんなやり方で実践できるものなんですね
だから正式的に決まったパターンがないんですね
それはまあ良かったことでもありながら
困ったことでもあります
人間っていうのはなんかパターン決めた方がやりやすいということがありますね
礼の仕方 お辞儀の仕方
何くどれぐらい角度体を曲げるのか
あれやこれやとかね 精密にセンチミリ単位で決めた方がやりやすいってことはある
日本の場合はだいたい何でもしっかり決めておいた方がしっかりするっていうこともありますね
しかし もう一つもありますよ
自分が自由で 自分に理解できる
納得できる 気に入るやり方でやるっていうこともありますね
だからそれは臨機応変にバランと止めた方がいいんですよ
例えばご飯食べる時でも
しっかり世界が決めた決めたやり方で丁寧にご飯食べることもできるし
自分が歩きながら食べたければね
自分自身ではそれは気持ちいい場合もありますよ
だからそこはどんな風にやるのかって
その場でその場で決める生き方もいいんじゃないかなと思います
その中でどうしても変えられないものもありますけどね
はい それで慈悲の瞑想っていうのは
仏教の場合は智慧と気持ち
心を浄化すること 心の汚れがなくすことを考えている教えですから
心は自分持っているんですね
それは浄化するのは自分でやらなくちゃいけないんですね
で 人が洗ってくるならばね
すごいありがたいんだけどね
簡単でね 自分何もやらないでね
心だけはそうならないんですね
自分自身で心を綺麗にしなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで 慈悲の実践の場合も
これは心にある怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ 悩み ああいうものはなくす訓練なんですね
なくす訓練っていうのは
これちょっとでも感じとったら
あっということになっちゃって
それからそこを方法を見つけたら
自分で自分の心が続けていくんですね
基本的に何で私たちは腹が立ったり
これが嫌だなとかね 例えばこのホールの中は
ここら辺はちょびっと冷たそうな感じで
そちらはどうかわかりませんだけど
ちょっと冷たそうだなとか
外行ったらちょっと暑いなとかね
そこで微妙にちょっと暑いなとかね
というのはまあいいんだけど
嫌だな これは とかね って思う時もあるしね
なんでこうなるのかっていう時もありますね
私はこの瞬間瞬間の心をチェックしてみて
だからこの実験する場合は
自分の心は実験台だからね
それでちょっと実験してくれる時々ちょびっと
あ これはあかん これは嫌ということが出てくるんですね
この瞬間で その瞬間に
あ これ自我張ってるんだとかね
自我が張っているんだとかね
で 時々ね お釈迦様のろうそく立てるとやけどする時もありますけど
いやっていうことになっちゃうと
あ 自我張っている そういうことで
このどんな悩みも どんな苦しみも
自我張ると出てくるんですね
だからまず悪い方で考えましょう
例えば子供がうるさいんですか？と聞いたら
うるさいね 子供はと それで自我張ってるんです
例えば私が子供がうるさいと思ったところで
私が自分で判断しておいて
自分が作った判断に子供が合ってないんですね
静かにいたいんだという自分の自我で決めていて
静かにいたいんだと決めたんだけど
これ子供がかなり騒ぎ大騒ぎしていて
それでイライラして もう時々おばあちゃんっているんで文句まで言うて子供うるさいやとかね
よくもおばあちゃんにそんなことを言うとね
だって子供育てた人間でしょうに
子供っていうのはうるさいのは決まってるでしょうに
だからまあそこで子供うるさいと文句言ったり
クレームつけたりする方々は
もうよく知らない自分たちにも子供がいたしね
育てたし やっぱり自我がその殻がものすごくきつくなっちゃって
それで不幸の世界が生まれてくる
だから自我が不幸を作るんです
例えば金がちょっとなくなったと
これは不幸じゃないんです
別に 自分が金がもういくらでもあってほしいという勝手な気持ち作っちゃ
ちゃうと金がないことは不幸なんです
で いつでもそうなるんで
私も最近もう体が昨日からね
すごく調子が壊れちゃって
ですごくきつい状態があったんですね
今はワンゲイさんにね
うるさくちょっと休み休めと言われて
まあちょっと休んで横になっていて
いくらか調子が戻りましたけどね
それでその時は私はもうあえて自我だけは張らないということにはするんですね
で 耐えられないぐらいものすごいきつい苦しみが生まれてくる
生まれてきても まあきついんだけど
自我張らないで苦しんでいると
何かとなんか面白くなってくるんですね
楽しくはなってこないんだけど
面白くなってくるんです
体調が悪くて超楽しいってことはないんだけど
あの悪い状態もなんか面白いんですね
ですから この何とかして我々は自我張らない人間になった方が
そこで幸福があるんですね
仏教でも年取ることは人間にとって苦しみであるとは言ってるんだけど
私たちにとっては年取ることは苦しみでたっていても
そんなものすごい苦しみである
これ 悩みにまでなるんですね
落ち込むところまでなる
それから年取ったら 自分があまりにも悩み落ち込み
我慢できなくて周りにも当たったりまでする
そういう人々は不幸なんですね
幸福はないんです 年取るもんだなとかね
自我張らないで現実だけ見ると
そんなもんだなねってふうに見ると
別に面白くなってくるんです
だから直ちに幸福になる
それは自我張ってる方々はこう思っちゃうんですね
サンケイして瞑想すればドカーンと幸福になって
なんか財産が四方が空から降ってきて
直ちに億万長者になると思ってるんですね
それが不幸なんです すごく穏やかな気分でいられることなんです
だから仏教が言う幸福っていうのは
雨が降っても寒気になっても幸福で
地震が起きてもそうでなく
穏やかな状況であっても幸福
そういう幸福なんです
いわゆる揺らがない 年取ったら年取ったで幸福
病気になったら病気になったでも幸福
風吹いただけで壊れる幸福っていうのは大したことないでしょう
だからあれ 自我なんですね
例えば世界の経済状況が悪い
だからもう落ち込んでいるとかね
大した人生じゃないね
その場合は だから経済状況悪かろうか
会社の状況は良かろうかもうきつかろうかって関係なく
穏やかにいられる この自我張らない世界で幸福なんですね
いわゆる揺らがない幸福
そこでどうなるのかというと
そういう人々ですよ 人を助けるのは
例えば災害 災難の時でも落ち着いて
まあまあまあ何のこともない
まあまあという感じで
そんな大騒ぎする必要はない
もうという感じでいる人にとっては
みんなを助けてあげることはできますよ
水がないところで ペットボトル1本の水がなかったら
じゃあそうですね  3人いるんだから
じゃあこれ3人で分けて飲みましょうよと
ああ 水がない  3人いるのにペットボトル1本しかない
どうしよう 苦しい 苦しい
こんなことではと言ったら地獄でしょ
それ そのペットボトル1本で例えば1日生活しなきゃいけないんだったら
明るい人がこれ 1口ずつ飲みましょうね
なんとなく体を騙そうよ
まだ水が入るまでという風に
それを面白くするんですね
だから必要に必要な水分がないんだけど
まあこれ細胞を騙してやりましょうか
なんか口にちょっと水を一口入れて
じっと待っていて ググンと飲むんじゃなくて
なんとなく流れるようにしましょうよと
おなかの中に そこ楽しいんですよ
だから このいかなる場合でも
そういう人々はみんなを助けてあげる人間なんです
だから 慈悲が入った人はみんな生命のリーダーなんです
だから 俗世間的な理解で理解しないで
お釈迦様がおっしゃった世界で
このブッダの教えを理解していきましょう
はい そういうことで慈悲の瞑想を行います
で なんで慈悲ですかね
面倒くさいでしょ 本当に面倒くさいんです
なぜかというと この生命っていうのは
この なんか変な例えで言うならば
鬼が作ったみたいなもんなんです
神様は西洋の宗教から言えば
神様はサタンであると
サタンがサタンというんですか
日本語で サタンが悪魔ですね
が すべての物事を作ったような感じなんです
どんな生命も自分のことしか考えない
他の生命をもうやりたい放題
もういじめてやりまくりたいんですね
それだったら人間を作ったのは慈悲深い神じゃなくてサタンなんですよ
で 我々はそういう生き方をしているんです
現実を見てください 例えばみんなに優しくしなさいと
もううるさくなるほど口酸っぱくして言わなくちゃあかんでしょ
それでも聞いてくれない
でも 悪いことをする人間が誰から学んでるんですかね
人をいじめる人なんかは
それごく自然にやっちゃいますね
嫌な人に対して怒ること
怒鳴ること 自然でしょ
誰も教えてくれなくてもできます
しかし 嫌な人とは思わないで
なんとか頑張ってと言っちゃうと
すごいストレスかかっちゃうんです
優しく振る舞う場合は
これ理解しましょう 我々は本当に恐ろしい心で
精神の力で生きているんですね
弱肉強食というよりも
このもう何て言いますか
この 食い争いような破壊ししちゃう
何でも壊しちゃう それが結構気分がいいんです
なんで気分がいいのかというと
心の本能がそういうものすごい汚れて汚いんだから
だから慈しみの人間になる
ことは結構富士山に登るような感じで
最も難しいかも エベレストに登るような感じで
でも結構我慢 頑張らないと精進しないと
だからこの世の中の人々は本当にもう言ってることは嘘なんですよ
もうもう愛やらあんなもだとか言うんだけど
もう本来そんなものはないんですね
だから自分の心を見て
これとんでもない原子爆弾みたいな心だと
自分の心が壊れた原子炉みたいだと
これ完全に放射能をなくしちゃって
役に立つものにしなくちゃいけないという風に
もう努力して 修行して
精進して この聖なる世界に進化しなくちゃいけないんです
だからお釈迦様もね 人間というのはもう地獄に不幸に落ちる人々っていうのはものすごいんだと
上上進んでいく人々は少ないんですよ
だから自然の流れに沿っても
滑るのは滑りやすいんだけど
登るのは難しいでしょうに
滑ることで怪我するんだけど
しっかりと登ったら怪我はしませんね
はい ですから このたとえ生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという時でも
これ覚えておいてください
これ結構大変なことだとそう思わなくてはいけないんだと
そうそう 自分が無理をしなくちゃいけないんだ
宿題なんだ 宿題っていうのは
何のことなくできるものだったら宿題じゃないでしょ
いくらか考えて いくらか苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 皆様 今試験を受ける歳の方々はいないように見えますけど
例えばね 若者はね いろいろ試験がありますよ
で 免許もたくさん免許証もありますからね
いろんな試験がありますね
料理屋さんになろうとみても
何か試験がありますね
で あれも聞いたんですけど
あのあと あの フグ フグをさばくことにもライセンスを取らないとね
禁止なんですね だから何にも試験がありますよ
試験っていうのは いたって簡単だったら試験にならないでしょ
だから大学生に まあ小学生の
あるいは中学生程度 の試験問題出したっても
試験でも何でもない それで能力は測ることできませんね
だから 日常生活の中で
我々はいつでもいろんな試練やら試験やら
そういうものに遭遇しなくちゃいけない
その時はちょっと頑張らなくちゃいけない
それで生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにということは
人格を完成するための試験なんです
フレーズは簡単だけど
繰り返すたびにそれを思い出したらどうですかね
一回生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますから
それぐらいちょっと厳しく感じて
もう二回 二回目 もうちょっと厳しく感じてどうかね
だから脳がそこを変えるまでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
変わってしまうまで それは慈悲の正しいやり方
それでなぜ慈悲を行うべきかというと
生命っていうのはいつでもネットワークで成り立つもので
個人で生活することは絶対不可能です
だから自我がないというんですね
仏教ではそうだからではなくて
それも一つの理由なんです
単独で生きられません
我々はいわゆる人間だ
人間だと言っているんだけど
これ 40兆の細胞たちが共同作業で共同作業で互いに助け合って
互いのことを心配し合っているから
この人間という幻覚が成り立つんです
幻覚です 一個一個細胞は別々な生命体だから
細胞単単一で生活できるかというと
無理 すぐ死にます それは誰かにつながっちゃって助けてもらっているんです
助けもらうだけではなくて
繋がった相手もこっちだから何か助けてもらわなくちゃいけないんですね
だから全宇宙の生命っていうのは
私のこの体の中と同じです
体の中でいろんな形の細胞たちがいるんです
いろんな能力 高い近い能力を持っている
皮膚の細胞持っている能力は筋肉細胞は持ってないんです
筋肉細胞を持ってる能力は骨の細胞を持ってないんです
目の細胞を持ってる能力は
他の細胞組織は誰も持ってないんです
全く互い違うんですよ
同一なものじゃないんです
でも仲良くやってるでしょ
そこでよくわかることは
この細胞単位で命やと言ったら
この細胞たちは自我を張ってないんです
心臓細胞が私がなかったらお前らなんだよ
は思わないんですね すごく下向きに謙虚で一生懸命頑張ってるんです
すごいシンプルな仕事
パイプポンプ まあ就職すると就職して就職して
がふんがふんがふんがふん
そればっかり一生やってるんですよ
なんでここまで仕事する私は昇格しないの？とかね
皆様みたいなあんなくだらん文句言わないです
この会社でも６年も仕事をしていますけど
全く全然もう給料も上がりませんよとかね
上司は私を褒め称えてくれませんよとかね
何言ってるんですかね
考えてみたら 私たちよりどれほど心臓細胞仕事をしていますかね １
分間何回ですかね まあ一応落ち着いていても
まあ私の場合はまあ６８ ７０
あたりで １分間で それまあ１００までいく場合も人によってありますけど
でも心臓細胞は１回でもデモを起こしたことないんです
私のことを大事にする
もっと昇格してくれとかね
いらない 期待もしない
ただ 心臓細胞たちに必要な栄養だけ入れば十分です
だから心臓は血液を送るんだけど
悪用はしませんね 心臓細胞の必要な栄養はまた別な血管であげなくちゃいけないんです
みんな平等なんです だからたくさん栄養が必要だから
結構血管がありますけどね
だからものすごい仕事をするんだから
脳細胞と心臓細胞が結構栄養をとってますね
しかし あれは高い給料をもらってますよ
でもちゃんとしたシステムでいただいているのであって
血管が細いんだから 中いっぱい血液がありますから
ここから取ってやるぞとかね
はやりませんね 人間どうですかね
もう金扱ってるということは
できることならやっちゃうでしょ
給料以外に はい そういうことで
私たちに客観的に世の中を見ると
自分の体を見るだけで十分です
体の細胞たちはすごく謙虚で
慈経でアナティマーニという言葉があったんで
慈悲の実践する前に資格がありますよと
自我張らないこと 高慢にならないこと
それからスバロウジという単語がありますね
いわゆる面倒見やすい人間になりなさいと
私の言葉では細胞から学びなんですよ
細胞はそんなにわがまま張らない
自分に与えられた栄養分で生きているんですね
細胞は壊れる時は文句言いませんよ
自然に壊れていく それで新しい細胞がバトンタッチをして仕事を続けている
そういうことで この体見たら互い違い
細胞たち 寿命が互い違い
一番早くなくなるのは血液細胞ですけど
で 白血球にはね もう核さえもないんですからね
だから自我あることはどうやったてもできません
細胞核もないんです  それでも早く寿命がなくなるし
でも新しい新しい細胞が出てきて仕事をやり続けている
全宇宙の生命 みんな同じことなんです
互い違うんです 互い違うことは殺し合いやりなさいじゃないでしょ
そこで自我張ったらどれほど悪いかと
皆さんはよく知っています
がん細胞 嫌でしょ がん細胞はものすごい嫌なんです
なぜがん細胞嫌かというと
えらい自我張ってるんですね
栄養を奪っているんです
勝手に成長する 細胞たちは成長するのは必要だ時
必要な量なんです 体指が切られたら
そこで新しい細胞が生まれますよ
必要だからね それできれいに治ったらストップするんです
それにしたら がん細胞はどうですかね
増えるは増えるは増えるは
何の役にも立ちません
自分だけが肥やす あんたここまで栄養取ってるんだったら
何か仕事もしなさいよ
いやいや 私に給料ください
仕事はしませんという態度なんです
だからシステム壊すでしょ
他の細胞組織にはもういる場所もなくなっちゃうんです
肺にがん細胞が入っちゃうと
肺に仕事できなくなる
全部あちらに取られちゃうんだから
なぜ人死んじゃうんです
だからなんで生命は人間だけじゃなくて
がん細胞になってるんですかね
それってすごい非科学的
非科学的でしょ がん細胞になったらすべて壊れます
だから我々は一人一人がこの全全体生命システムの中で
がん細胞にならないことなんです
そうすると すごく穏やかに自分の寿命を全うすることができます
だから私は悪魔のサーペントの話を持ってきたんです
協力しなきゃ生きていられないのに
作ったのは生命を作るのはサタンだから殺し合いやりなさいと
それで簡単に殺し合いやっちゃうんですね
まあ最近は面白い本を読んでますよ
あの 悪魔の日記という
で シリーズですごい面白いんですね
普通人間書かない見方で悪魔たちの世界を描いてるんです
デビルス何だったっけかな
デビルスタイル すごい面白いんです
そういうことで 悪魔を退治しなくちゃいけないんです
そこで幸福が成り立つのです
だから慈悲がない人は
だから自分の四十兆の細胞命があって
自分という一個の命というでしょ？一個って命なってないんですけどね
四十兆の あまりやらないんだけど
私は時々やってみたんですよ
細胞たちに慈しみを与えたらどうですかと
だから自分と違って ああ
あんた方も元気で幸福でありましょうにと
やっぱりその日は気分がいいんです
気分がいい 体調がいいんです
だから体の中の他の生命として見た方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
まああんまりお釈迦様はそういうついてないんだから
まあよくやりませんだけど
ちょっと実験的にやってはみたんです
だから 目に見える見えない
長いもの 短いもの 太っているもの
小さいもの まあ何でもいいんだけど
生命は様々 互い違い でもすべて一つの命で見たらどうですか？ヒンドゥー教と同じく
こういうのはブッダの言葉ではないんだけど
あのブッダの日でブッダの言葉でないものを言っちゃうのはね
まあよく調子がいいもんですね
私も なんとなく この慈しみ
優しさを理解していただくためなんです
体の中で細胞たちが互い違いでよかったならば
なんで世の中で生命は互い違いが悪い？おかしいでしょ
あの人変やと言えないでしょ
バカでない限りは あの人は変ではなくて
あの人は違う 当たり前です
違います この互い違いだからこそ命が成り立っているんです
例えば あの料理できる人を見てできない人もいるでしょ
それで世界が成り立っているんです
じゃなきゃもう証明にならないでしょ
それで生きていられないんですね
例えば どんな人間もものすごく美しく歌える
歌唱力がある そうなるとどうなる？満期音楽っていうことは消えちゃうんです
世の中から しかし現実は 1万人選べる
調べると歌える人は一人ぐらいですね
その人だけ特別に生態系ができていて
恵まれていると我々言うんだけど
別に恵まれていると言わなくたっていいんです
その人は互い違いんですね
その違うことでその生命体が出てくるんです
だから違う美しい人がいて
汚い人もいる それでいいんです
算数に算数はものすごい上手な人がいて
もう足し算もろくにできない人がいる
それでいいんです 世の中は
例えばこのいろいろもう障害持ったり
身体障害やったり そういう人々いるでしょ
ありがたいんです なぜ？で
そういう人々いるんだから
そういう人々のお世話をするという役目が現れてるんです
だから この この互い違い
英語で言えばディファレンスなんですね
ディファレンスイズビューティフルという言わなくちゃいけないんです
この同一性なんかもうありえない
それが知恵の世界というんです
と言っても 私の細胞は協力してくれないんで
いろいろ吸ったりいろいろ
はい そういうわけで 私たちは協力し合う
料理上手な人は料理作る
後片付けできない人は後片付けをする
する 服装をデザインにできる人はそれをやっている
お化粧の技術を持ってる人はそれをやっているとかね
それぞれの互い違いで助け合っている
だから仏教は豊かな人は貧しい人を助けなさいよ
これ義務なんです 特別お布施
寄付 あれやこれやとか偉そうなことを言う必要さえないんです
すいません ちょっと失礼します
じゃあ机を揃えましょうか
はい はい これで理解できたでしょうね
この互い違いということだから
慈悲が必要なんです それを認めなくちゃいけない
慈悲 慈悲を実践する人に嫌な生命がないんです
それがなかったら困りますからね
皆様 ゴキブリのこと嫌いだけど
それは私たちの主観でわからないだけで
ゴキブリっていうのは存在に対して要らないものだったら
もうとっくに恐竜みたいな感じで消えているんですよ
我々よりしっかりいるのはね
もし人間が地球上から消えてしまったらね
ゴキブリはいるんだから
だって放射線が当たっても大丈夫ですから
あの連中は 福島の方にいるんですよ
いっぱい 動物たちは そうすると
次の命システムが現れるでしょ
放射線にとっては何のびくともしない
そういうわけだから どんな生命を見ても自分でわからないかも
なんでゴキブリ？なんでシロアリいるのかとかね
迷惑やとかね 人間家作らなかったら迷惑じゃないでしょ
シロアリは硬い木を食べてくれてね
地球に栄養を与えていますけど
皆さんはあまりシロアリの実際の経験ないですよ
私たちには自分の国でありますから
シロアリが土を変えるんですよ
素晴らしく変える あの土がこの粘土みたいな感じに土が変わるんですね
で それ固めたら干した天日で干したってこ
それから水を入れることもできます
あれどうやってやるのかとわからない
あの連中がやってくれるんです
で 昔 自分の国ではね あの
昔の時代では この土で壁とか作るんですよ
なんのことはない ただシロアリの塚を掘って掘って
土を持ってきて練って
それからもう土壁作るんです
だから地震にも壊れませんし
大丈夫で 雨がもし屋根がなくて雨が降ったっても
壁は大丈夫ですよ だってアリ塚はいくら雨が降ったっても大丈夫ですから
そこでシロアリ塚を掘ることでシロアリに迷惑かというとそうでもないんです
シロアリは引っ越しするんですよ
だから実際シロアリが住んでるところの土はそれほど役に立たない
シロアリがもうもう空き家にした塚が人間の役に立ちます
だから生命がね 私にわからないからといってね
この我々はウイルスに対してすごい嫌な気持ちを持ってるでしょ
でもウイルスも必要なんです
そういうことで 互い違い
それで我々はわざと協力しよう気持ちを作る
自我がダメなんです  40兆の細胞は別々な命だと思ったら
自分っていうのはどんな細胞ですかね？どんな細胞が自分ですかね
1個もないでしょ 自分消えちゃうんです
みんなこの現代知識でね
脳細胞自分ではないかと思うんだけど
脳細胞そんなこと考えても何もないんです
脳細胞を調べると忙しいんですよ
見ることやらデータ処理することやら
体を管理することやら
もう臓器別にやってるんです
自我を張ることできないんです
自我張るモジュール システムが脳の中にないんです
だからこれすごい幻覚なんです
私という言葉さえも だからさらにさらにこういう瞑想して知恵を開発して
この素晴らしい世界を発見しましょう
では 言葉を読み上げましょうか
まず私が幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますように
私と一緒にやりましょう
私の心に現れる悩み 苦しみが徐々に消えていきますように
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの感情は人の心を苦しめます
苦しみである怒り 嫉妬
憎しみが私の 心に起こりませんように
怒り心と憎しみの妄想を育てないように努めます
私の思考が慈しみの思考になりますように
私は物事が常に変化して消え去るものであると観察します
私は過ぎ去った出来事にとらわれないように精進します
私は将来のことに執着して悩まない
不安にならない人間になります
私は今ここでするべきことに集中します
今までの説法はこういう風に実践します
はい それから他者に対するところに行きます
私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
自分の精神状態を直して
しっかりして 他者のところまで行くんで
ここで慈悲と智慧と合わせた瞑想なんですね
だから完全完全ということになりませんだけど
そういうバージョンですね
はい いきます 私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
他者に対して優しい心で対応することができますように
私の心に他を差別する気持ちが現れませんように
苦しい状況に遭遇しても忍耐することができますように
私の心が常に平安でありますように
私の心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
私にありのままの事実を発見することができますように
私に真理を発見する智慧が現れますように
私に一切の現象に対する愛着がなくなりますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
はい 次のページに行きます
すべての生命は兄弟ということで
私はすべての生命が私の兄弟であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命と私が平等であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命の幸福と繁栄を期待します
私は生命の間で調和が保たれるように精進します
これ短いですから 二回繰り返しましょう
私はすべての生命が私の兄弟であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命と私が平等であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命の幸福と繁栄を期待します
私は生命の間で調和が保たれるように精進します
私はすべての生命が私の兄弟であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命と私が平等であると思える
証人します 私はすべての生命の幸福と繁栄を祈念します
私は生命の間で調和が保たれるように精進します
はい 次にお釈迦様の言葉を
お釈迦様の教えをね 省略したところですけど
これはいろんな経典を参考にして作った文章なんですね
たった一つのどんな経典ですかと聞いても
もう全部読み読まないと
はい そういうことでお釈迦様の言葉を念じましょう
私は釈尊の言葉を念じます
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の母ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の父ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の兄弟ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の子供ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の友人ではなかった生命はいません
釈尊の戒めを尊んで 一切の生命に慈しみの気持ちを抱きます
すべての生命は私自身の父
母であると思います すべての生命は私自身の兄弟であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の子供であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の友人であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の家族であると思います
すべての生命は幸福でありますように
はい そういうことで みんな一つの家族として感じること
なんで別々にしたのかというと
その時 時 その時 気分次第で母と思うこともできるし
子供と思うこともできる
その気分次第なんです
そこで心の自由を与えているんです
ある人を見たら なんかお母さんみたいに感じること
簡単だったらお母さんやと思う
ある人はまあおじいちゃんじゃないかなと思ったらそう思っちゃう
あ これは私の子供みたいやと思ったら
そういう風な気持ちを抱ける
だから このいろんな生命はいろいろ年齢があって
性別があって いろんな立場があって
性格が違う 違うんだから
それに合わせて我々は家族関係を作るんです
母にしたり 叔父にしたり
兄ちゃんにしたり 妹にしたり
娘にしたり 息子にしたり
友達にしたり いとこにしたり
そういうふうなことで
自分の心を自由に動かしてみてください
はい これでちょっと ぐっつく
もう聖者たちの世界に入ります
まあ慈悲を完成したらどんなものかと
やっぱりゴールをあそこまでやとね
知った方がもうやりやすい場合あります
まあストレスになる 我々はゴールを決めたらストレスになっちゃいますけど
この場合 ストレスにならないんです
何か決めたらすごいストレスなんですよ
これ 例えば締め切りは明日だよと私に言われたら
もうかなりページ数が長い本が訂正編集し
訂正しなくちゃいけない
ストレスかかりますよ
俗世間ではそうなんですけど
慈悲の場合はここまで上がってこいというあったあった方がやりやすい
そこで聖者たちは自我を消しちゃうんです
だから今の 40兆の細胞はもう勝手ですからね
自分がいないんですね
より 40分の細胞たちが何やってるかよくわかりませんよとね
どうぞどうぞ頑張ってくださいという風になったら
自分がいなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで わかりやすい例えは空のように気持ちは
で この日本語で空と言ったって
この宇宙空間のようなんですね
パーリ語の言葉は 宇宙空間のように
それに自我がないということなんです
だから自我がないということはすごい広いんですよ
自我はもうぐっと狭くするんですね
自分を 宇宙空間のように広げた精神で生きられるのに
このままですね 肉体に閉じ込められて小さい
はい 心は空気のように
空気と空気が何の対立も無く一体になるように
私の慈しみの気持ちがすべての生命の心と一体になりますように
水と水が何の対立もなく一体になるように
太陽の光が地球の隅から隅まで照らすように
私の慈しみの光がすべての生命の心を妨げなく照らせるように
制限なく慈しみを育みます
東西南北上下という六方に住む生命に対して
無限に留まることなく慈しみを育みます
時間どうなっていますか？そういうことで
これも 3回繰り返さなくちゃいけないんだけど
ちょっとイメージを作って
私の心は空気のように
水のようにというね 即刻泣けますよと
どんな心も はい 次 私の心は大地のように
これもあのお釈迦様もサーリプッタ尊者も説かれている例えから取りました
大地を見たら慈しみを実践できますよ
大地っていうのは すべての生命がね
大地の上に生活しているでしょうに
だから 各生命が生きることで大地がダメージを受けるんですよ
私たちは大地の恵みで生きているでしょ
生きてくれてるんだけど
生かしてくれているんだけど
私がダメージを与えているんですね
他の生命も同じでしょう
鳥たちであろうが 他の生き物であろうが
大地のおかげで生きているんですよ
かえってその生き方が大地に対してはちょっと迷惑だなという状態なんです
しかし 大地は何のこともない
我々は何かダメージ受けてんだからといって
そのうち元に戻る だからその心なんですね
その例えですよ 慈しみの心に
やりましょう 大地はいかなる清らかなものを捨てても
いかなる不浄なものを捨てても
喜ぶことも嫌がることもありません
私も他の生命の称賛 非難などを受けるときは
大地のような心を保ちます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
失敗して怒ったりとかね
失敗するときはすぐ大地の例えを思い出してください
はい 次 別なスタンスで辞 reading を見るんですね
これは業ですね 業を理解することができれば
理解はできないと思いますけど
いくらか納得してね 神が生かしてるんじゃなくて
業が生命を生かしてるんだということは論理的な結論なんです
ブッダの場合はもう証拠済みですけど
私たちには論理的に結論に達しなくちゃいけないんです
業っていうのは心の心の中にある衝動というか
エネルギーなんですね
いつでも皆様感じていると思います
なんか心がなんかやりたい
なんかやりたい なんかやりたい
なんかやりたいといつでもあるんですよ
このなんかやりたいなんですけど
何をやりたいっていうことは業で決めちゃうんですね
だからみんないろんなことをバラバラなことをやっています
何かやりたいっていうところはみんな同じなんです
何をやりたいかということによって
業がその流れを決めるんです
だから絵を描きたいという人もいて
楽器演奏したいという人もいて
まあ服を作りたいという人もいて
いろんな人がいるんですね
なんかやりたいんです
みんな同じことをやりたくはないんですね
だから 各生命が業によって生かしているんです
ある生命が体が小柄としましょう
その業が小柄の体を作ったんです
ある生命の体がすごい大きいとしましょう
業がその大きい体が作ったんです
遺伝子でもないんですよ
時々すごい小柄な子供がいて
すごい大型の子供が生まれるということはありますよ
そういうことで この遺伝子説明はすごい物足らないんですね
これは道は業が決めるんです
視力はあるかないか 聴覚の能力あるかないか
もうスタミナはどんな程度にあるかないか
業が決めたんです だからこれ私にとって仕方がないでしょ
例えば私の体はこんな形で
筋肉もすごく衰えちゃって
まあ仕方がないんですね
私は皆様体力ある皆様のことを
恨んだり なんで私に神様がこんな体をくれたのかどうか
バカバカらしいんです
だから  まあどうやってことでね
ゴーヤではなくて あの業であると
[笑い]と思っちゃえばもう
落ち着く あの子供たちなんかね
そこいじめやってるでしょ
この体がちょっと大きいんだったら
ちょっとお腹が大きいんだったら
まあいじめる 鬼ですよ
結局は 体が弱くてな もうそろっていじめる
走れない子はいじめる
何なの 走れる子も走れない子もいるんだから
それはもう その子はもうもうどうにもならんでしょうに
だからカラスの体形はカラス
その業がその形にしているんです
だからカラスは白い白くなってほしいと思ってもね
それはあんまり自分が困るだけで
そういうことで このお釈迦様が全ての生命は業によって生まれて
業によって管理されて
業のままで生きているんだと
生まれること 寿命 体の形
能力 色 すべて業で決めているんです
細胞変化はその業に決めた道で
ブループリントでいくんです
はい 読みいきましょうか
みんな業を創設します
すべての生命は自分の業を創設します
自分の業に管理されて生きています
各生命が受ける幸不幸はその生命の業の力によるものです
ですから 私は私より豊かな人を見るたびに
過去に善行為をした人であると思い
喜びを感じます 私より不幸に思える人を見ると
生命は無明のせいで罪を犯すのだと理解し
自分が罪を犯さないようにと誓っています
不幸に陥っている生命に対して
憐れみの気持ちを抱きます
協力する 助ける気持ちを起こします
そういうことで なんで私が不幸やっていう
あの 何て言いますか 文句を捨てて捨てましょう
なんで私は不敬と人のことを見て
この人なら幸せなのに
なんで私が？とかね これでもう悪魔の言いなりになっちゃうんですね
関係ないんです 私の業は私のことで
そちらの業はそちらの業で
自分から見たらなんか幸せに見えるんだったら良かったねと
その方が善行をしたんだと
で 不幸やと思う人だったらかわいそうだなあとかね
悪いことするもんじゃないなあとかね
思ってから その人を助けなくちゃいけないんです
それで自我を張ることはできなくはなります
はい 次 エゴの錯覚  そこでまあ智慧の世界に入ります
私は他より優れていると感じることは高慢です
私は他と同等だと思うことは同等慢です
私は他より卑しい存在であると思うことは卑下慢です
慢とは私のエゴの錯覚から起こるのです
私はエゴの錯覚が心に現れないようにと精進します
私は慢により現れる対立
悩み 争いから離れるようにと精進します
はい 最後に 最後じゃない
まだあります また 経典から受け取った文章から長いセクションを作ってあります
苦しむ世界で苦しみなく
これ 殺伐的な気持ちじゃないんですね
慈しみがない人は苦しむんです
仕方がないんです だから慈しみを育てなくちゃいけないんです
釣り餌を食っちゃったらもうもう死にますよ
もうパクッと食ったのは誰ですか？と
だからこの みんなやってないからっていう理由を出すでしょ
あれ悪魔の言葉なんですね
みんなやってることをやるっていうことは大したことないでしょう
だから互い違うことをやらなくちゃいけないでしょう
だから呼吸することに何か競争ありますか？あの人は物事に物の見事に呼吸したんだから
このトロフィーあげますとか
誰もやりませんよ バカバカらしいことを
誰もやってることだから
トロフィーあげるのは他の人のできないことをやったからでしょうに
だから他の生命には慈しみを実践しないからといって
私もやりませんと すごいけしからんな考えなんです
それからみんなやってないんだから
仏教はちょっと恥ずかしいよと
ものすごいけしからんのです
誰も興味持ってないから自慢して胸を張ってやった方がいいんです
なぜなら これ智慧の世界だから
智慧はすごい世界でしょう
はい 始まります 苦しむ世界で苦しみなく
世界は欲によって苦しんでいることを観察して
私は欲を控えることに精進します
世界は怒りによって苦しんでいることを観察して
怒りのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は嫉妬によって苦しんでいることを観察して
嫉妬のない心で生きるように精進します
世界は恨みによって苦しんでいることを観察して
恨みのない心で生きるように精進します
世界はものを惜しみによって苦しんでいることを観察して
物惜しみのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は自我を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
自我を張らない心で生きるように精進します
世界は見栄を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
見栄を張らない心で生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無常であることを気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無常であると認めて生きるように精進します
世界 は一切の現象は苦であることを気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は苦であると認めて生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無我であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無我であると認めて生きるように精進します
私の心に悩みが起こりませんように
私の心に苦しみが起こりませんように
私の心は平安でありますように
私の心に安らぎが現れますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
カンティーパラマンタコーティティンカー
忍耐と堪忍は最高の修行であります
ニッバーナニャンパラマンツカン
涅槃は究極の幸福であります
そういうことで 最高な修行なんですよ
忍耐 堪忍というのは 我々は互い違い生命にて忍耐しない
堪忍しない 潰そうとする
自分と同じにさせようとする
それで修行では仏道ではなくなっちゃうんです
忍耐する それは修行です
最後に忍耐することはなくなっちゃうんです
認めたところで ディファレンスというのは当たり前だとわかったら
別に忍耐というのもなくなっちゃうと
それで修行完成ですね
はい 最後の文章やって終了します
慈しみを宇宙まで拡大しなくちゃいけない
宇宙といっても広範的宇宙という生命ですね
生命は無限にいますから
拡大しなくちゃいけない
私の上の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の下の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の前の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の右の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の後ろの方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の左の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
幸福で安穏でありますように
怒り 憎しみ 恨みから自由になりますように
互いに慈悲喜捨の気持ちで接し合えますように
願い事が叶えられますように
心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
すべての生命に苦しみを乗り越えることができますように
サルーサルーサルー はい
それで慈悲の実践終了です
サルーサルー